a very good to talk to you well
um reports then of this strike on a NATO
country what are the priorities right
now
well the absolute top priority is to
establish what actually happened because
if we take or anybody takes decisions on
poor information then we're bound to
make poor decisions so the really
important thing is to gather information
as to what actually happened and then
there needs to be a rapid assessment as
to
analyzing what happened and why it
happened
um I think I think that part of this
stage there were two major explanations
one it was an error on the part of the
Russians
um that might be right it might not be
right equally the alternative
explanation is that it's something of a
test to see what uh NATO will do
um as your correspondents are said in
the press conference which you were
carrying earlier made quite clear an
attack on a Nato one NATO member is a
breach of Article Five and therefore
it's intact on all member states but um
we want to make sure that we don't rush
into a wider conflict as a result of
calculation uh or a mistake so
establishing what's happened is really
important I think cool heads need to
analyze uh what our response should be
but at this stage we should be very very
cautious
well in terms of that NATO response as
you say as we we all know by now this
article 5 of the treaty that an attack
on one NATO nation is an attack on them
all before that of course is Article 4
which would call for emergency
consultations that perhaps is the route
that Poland might initially follow
well I would certainly hope so because
um we all know that George Orr is better
than war war so
um the open channels and the back
channels should be being worked
vigorously at the present moment to try
and find out
not just what happened but why it
happened
um
modern technology is pretty accurate so
it's quite difficult to explain a way
that um this might have been an accident
if it wasn't an accident then actually
it was a test of of the West's response
and that's something that um got to be
thought through very very carefully and
that's why I said just now cool heads
are required to make sure that this
appalling War does not get escalated as
a result of miscalculation or a quick
decision on behalf of a degree party but
of course you're done at what is not in
doubt yet again today is the series this
wave of missile strikes by Russia on
many many targets civilian Targets in
Ukraine seen as thumbing their nose
after the G20 Summit in which president
zielinski addressed that Summit referred
to it as the g19 of course saying that
Russia really should be excluded it
clearly is
almost or is it already a rogue State
now
well um there's no doubt at all that um
the tough words spoken at the G20 have
been met by probably almost a
predictable response by Russia to
continue its outrageous attack on
Ukrainian civilian targets we've seen it
over the last three or four or five
weeks that Vladimir Putin wants to
destroy as much of the critical National
infrastructure of Ukraine that he
possibly can particularly targeting
their electricity capability which of
course then gets into water and all the
rest of it to make life as miserable as
possible for Ukrainian people because he
has this rather naive thought that he
could break the will of the Ukrainian
people and they'll change their mind
about the war
um we have a Ukrainian couple living
with us here in Norfolk
um they're not going to have their minds
Changed by that I don't think that
people in Ukraine will so it's a very
naive thought that he's got but it's
it's a pathetic reaction to the tough
words spoken of the G20 that once again
and the Russians launched a myriad of
missiles at Ukrainian targets and then
of course for good measure there's this
swipe at Poland and of course this is a
classic Putin tactic and over the last
five ten years he's posed various
questions of the West that big Cyber
attack on Estonia the intervention in
Syria and various other events that he's
engineered he just wants to know what
our response is going to be because what
he really really wants is to get a
fracture within the unidivity of NATO
and the West that's what he that's what
he hopes for most to try and get the
West to fracture and for us to start
disagreeing amongst ourselves and that's
why this attack in Poland we absolutely
need to know the information we need to
be very clear in our analysis very
cool-headed about it and then decide
what the right thing to do is and as
things currently stand probably to
accept although the lame excuse for the
Russians if Hood but actually it was a
mistake but um we don't want to rush
into a wider wall as a result of a
miscalculation but would the Russians
even go that far we uh know their form
on that they'll claim it's a false flag
the the ukrainians did it all the polls
did it or or NATO did it but if NATO
does establish that this was Putin
testing the waters testing the Border
what should the response be to show that
NATO will not crumble
well we need to see what the Russian
response is remember the uh near Miss of
the rivet joint aircraft which the
Russians said was a mistake well we the
UK accepted that
um as a reasonable explanation but as we
as I said just now we don't want to get
into a wider wall as a result of
miscalculation you mentioned Article 4
article 4 is absolutely right that all
the channels and communication should be
opened to for Poland to actually say to
the Russians you know what is going on
here and it's really important that
there is as much discussion and
understanding and negotiation as
possible because if we take the
alternative
um explanation that this was a
deliberate attack on Poland then it puts
us into Article 5 territory and that is
a very dangerous place to be because it
then poses the question to Nato what are
you going to do I don't think we want to
be there we want to be very very
cautious and just watch the situation
very clearly understand what actually
has happened but be pretty cautious
without being cautious doesn't mean to
say we're going to be weak but what we
don't need to be is to be rash and
escalate unnecessarily